haben sie sich auch das Medien Event das
jahrhunderts reingepfiffen die Charles
Krönung wie Game of Thrones
nur halt ohne Drachen ohne Spannung und
ohne Handlung dafür ein von Harald
Glööckler eingekleideter schlecht
gelaunter
am angeblich schönsten Tag seines Lebens
er kann es nicht so zeigen würde ich mal
sagen ja Gefühle sind nicht so Seins
andere würden sagen Alter ich habe
Jahrzehnte auf diesen einen Moment
gewartet wie geil ist das denn King
Charles hingegen sitzt frisch gekrönt in
seiner Kutsche muss ganz kurz warten und
hat direkt den Kaffee auf ja blöd wenn
dann lippenleser in der Nähe sind
langweilig
ein 74-jähriges verwöhntes Riesenbaby
als sie endlich losgefahren sind hatte
die ganze Fahrt über gefragt sind wir
bald da
kriechen Angst ich muss Pipi
so aber der eigentliche TV Horror waren
wie immer die Gesprächsrunden mit den
sogenannten Adelsexperten Alter nervt
das rTL hatte sogar einen spirituelles
Medium am Start die spürt aus Köln
Sachen über Charles und Camilla die will
man echt nicht hören beide haben eine
ganz tolle Beziehung wirklich auch bis
zum heutigen Tage so sehe ich das auch
eine sehr ja leidenschaftliche Beziehung
auch ein darf man das sagen ein
sensationelles Sexleben es ist so ja
bitte
was soll denn das man hat direkt so
Tierdokus mit alten Schildkröten im Kopf
warum macht sie das Plus natürlich die
ganze Schnappatmung wegen Prinz Harry oh
der in Ungnade gefallene Prinz durfte
nicht mit auf den Balkon und in der
Westminster Abbey saß eine dritten Reihe
zusammen mit Prinz Andrew also bei den
Sex aufendern ja ja Entschuldigung er
saß bei den Gästen das muss man so hart
sagen
und vor der Kirche das finde ich
eigentlich wichtiger vor der Kirche
wurden derweil 64 monarchiegegner
friedliche Demonstranten festgenommen
und in den Tower geworfen wahrscheinlich
aufgrund eines neuen Gesetzes als
Achtung potenzielle Störer das ist
wirklich Moskau Style das Gesetz als
Störer gilt jetzt zum Beispiel in
England jeder der in einem öffentlichen
Ort das Enthüllungsbuch von Prinz Harry
liest das geht offensichtlich gar nicht
und klar dann gibt es auch noch dreiste
Fälle von Amtsanmaßung durch falsche
Krone
neuerdings auch
illegal in Großbritannien ja das hat sie
davon einem alten Mann wird ein
glitzerhut aufgesetzt und den
Steuerzahler kostet das irgendwas
zwischen 100 und 300 Millionen Pfund in
einem Großbritannien in dem sich viele
Briten entscheiden müssen zwischen heat
oder eat heizen oder essen
inzwischen gibt es auf der Insel über
3000 food banks Tafel kurz gesagt
eigentlich hätte der Charles seine Party
selber bezahlen müssen oder können wir
hier sowas gar nicht beurteilen ohne
König herzlich willkommen zu unserer
neuen Rubrik
Monarchie von Gott gesegnet was ist
Republik die Herrschaft des dreckigen
Pöbels
ja Monarchie oder Republik das leite ich
doch direkt mal weiter an unseren
heute-show Adelsexperten Alexander
Freiherr von Wipprecht Herr welke
gestanden sie mir ein kurzes finnisches
really
really Monarchie das ist Kontinuität
Charts wurde auf einem Thron aus dem 13
jahrhundert gegründet er steht am Ende
einer endlosen Reihe von Cousins und
Cousinen bis zurück ins Mittelalter ein
familiäres Jahr haben inzestuöses Band
das sein Empire einfach zusammenhält
sowas haben wir hier gar nicht also
außer jetzt in Robert halbwegs
Ministerium
kleiner Scherz einfach mal spontan
eingeflochten wunderbar ja geht so ähm
ich habe ich habe mir die Krönung ja
leider auch angeguckt und frage mich ist
das noch zeitgemäß diese ganzen diese
Rituale dieser Mittelalter Fantasy Kram
ja ähm wie erkläre ich das einem
offensichtlichen Opfer des deutschen
Bildungssystems jeder einzelne
Gegenstand hat er natürlich eine hohe
symbolische Bedeutung
die rechte Hand von König Charles
denn diesen diesen Aufrichtigkeit und
der Weisheit Prinz William wird nun die
Stola seinem Vater umlegen
den krönungshandschuh
reicht da Lortzing auf Wimbledon ja
immer ein gutes Geschenk so ein Backofen
Handschuh
für die Königlichen dinkelplätzchen
in dem Moment war Gott im Raum manchmal
Gott Schatz wurde hinter einem neuen
ting Screen also einem salbungs Paravent
mit einem speziellen Öl aus Jerusalem da
ist Rosenduft drin Sesam zimt ist gibt
so viele unfassbar spannende Fakten
allein zu diesem Öl und es ist vegan ist
wirklich gerade sagen das ist vegan das
war es nämlich nicht immer dann ist gab
immer auch Substanzen die aus den
sozusagen Eingeweiden eines Wale standen
und aus der Analdrüse der zwiebelkatze
deswegen war das Öl früher so teuer
haben Sie mal in einer ziemlich Katze
die Analdrüse ausgedrückt ja die wird
sich
stimmt würde ich auch aber nochmal
nochmal 300 Millionen Pfund für
Handschuhe Zepter und veganes
analdrüsenöl ja warum denn nicht klar
viel Geld aber die Briten kriegen
wenigstens was dafür nämlich eine
richtig gute Show was kriegen wir denn
fürs Geld unsere ampelschaft in ihren
Ministerien immer mehr Stellen aktueller
Stand 37 parlamentarische
Staatssekretäre Rekord Olaf Scholz baut
sich eine neue kanzlerhütte für über 700
Millionen und bleibt trotzdem
stinklangweilig verstehe also wenn es
nach ihnen geht sollten wir auch
Monarchie werden wieso werden
ich weiß ja nicht ob sie Geschichte
hatten damals auf ihrer Hilfsschule aber
unser Kaiserreich hat bekanntlich nie
aufgehört zu existieren
Friedrich von hoch ach so sie sind
Reichsbürger was ich nein ich bin Bürger
des Deutschen Reichs und jetzt ist
und jetzt ist ihre Audios beendet meine
dumme bringen mich jetzt zurück in meine
Gemächer gehabt euch wohl gemein ist
Gesindel im Publikum
[Musik]
a hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den
Kanal abonnieren er deutet nach unten in
die Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]